zena's with us in DC hi Tina welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
taking my call sure your question for
dr. John okay I have a brother who's 49
years old he's on dialysis
which takes 3 to 4 hours about 4 times a
week he used to live with my mom until a
month ago when she passed away and when
he lived with her I would occasionally
help them out financially he is on
disability he gets over $600 a month he
is married his wife works inconsistently
they were there a one-car family and
they have an 18 year old who lives with
them so when they had to move out of my
mom's apartment because the lease was
done and it was in her name I actually
paid for a week for them at a hotel like
a real cheapo kind of place and I told
him I was done I wasn't helping anymore
because I felt like they didn't try to
help themselves when they had a free
place to say for years
at the same time you know I miss my mom
I am financially okay I can't help but
to me that kind of help is like okay
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing and your car breaks down and you
need your car to get to work so I helped
you get it repaired and not and you go
back on with your life but they just
can't keep it together and it's just
heart-wrenching because he really
doesn't find out gonna live a long life
you mean break out another year or two
but do you know I'm sorry about your mom
thank you and I know that's heavy let's
let's hold over the break and we'll talk
through this when we get back we're
talking with Tina in DC and her brother
her mom just passed away and her
brother's on dialysis and his family
with his 18 year old son and his wife
not working much are struggling
financially and continually coming to
her and she occasionally helps and
that's is that a fair summary while you
told us Tina yeah okay Tina is your
brother have any other kids is it just
the one 18 year old
he has two others and they have found a
way to make life work there better
results at the dull thing than he and my
car so a couple of things Dave and I
were talking about through the break I
think first and foremost for you is to
make sure that your grieving process the
way you find meaning in this grief is
not gonna be floating somebody else's
bad decisions or somebody else's bad
behavior which is different from being
sick and I hope that you catch the
nuance there does that make sense yes
because he had financial problems before
he would say okay and there's the
temptation for all of us is when we are
reeling from grief you just left your
mom you mentioned that your brother may
have 12 months may have 18 months the
temptation is gonna try to swoop in and
try to save this thing and try to be the
hero here and man we can if we don't
have some clear boundaries in our end we
can find ourselves so overextended and
then just in a big mess and so Dave
mentioned some great things off the year
thinking about will give you Financial
Peace University and you sit down with
them and say hey here's I'll be able to
help you this much money at this time
when you finish this plan we're going to
give you a carrot here and we're going
to support you here but it all comes
back to you creating really healthy
boundaries for yourself knowing that
you're not in a good place right now
because your mom just passed away and
you're looking at grieving the loss of
your brothers in a loving way like I
want to maintain the relationships I
have with him and his children yeah
that's a choice that they have to make -
what what I what I have done in these
situations is let's just sit down I'll
lead with I love you and your you know
mom's loss is breaking my heart and your
health is breaking my heart
and also your choices with money are
something I can't support so here's the
thing I can help you guys financially
only if you are taking steps that are
going to heal your finances I cannot be
giving a drunk a drink because that's
not me loving you well I love you too
much to participate in your misbehavior
with money by giving
you money so you can misbehave but if
you'll do some things and start to make
some steps through healing this NGO this
class I'll pay for it and and I'll you
know as soon as you complete that I you
know I'm gonna give you a thousand
dollars but I'm not going to just
randomly give you money oh and by the
way you go you guys
eighteen year old and the wife we've got
to get a job immediately and if you're
unwilling to do those things I still
love you but you need to know I can't
give you money if you're unwilling to
work and you're unwilling to work on
your money management skills because
that's enabling and Tina you've got to
be prepared for them to not be able to
hear that
yeah they there's a high probability
they're only gonna get angry all you
care about is money you don't care about
us now that mom's gone you're not a good
human all that stuff yeah so connection
goes two ways I always feel like my
brother he won't say that he'll just
emotionally kind of shut down and and
he's not emotionally strong enough and
never has been to get his wife to do the
things she needs to be doing and so
there's nothing never had to they've
never had to they lived it they lived
rent-free you helped step in and helps
they've never had to do that pouting is
not gonna work but you can't carry that
pain you can't carry that burden what
you have to come to the table with is a
clear plan for yourself in your heart
and say here's who I'm gonna be and I'm
gonna love you the problem is that I say
this all the time but I've something I
personally have walked through the
problem is when people that are grownups
are doing stupid things you have to
admit stupid is not illegal mmm you
can't make them stop and it just it's
hard it's hard but I will I tell you
what hold on Kelly I'll pick up will pay
for Financial Peace University but every
time charity is I am participating in
someone's healing enabling is I'm giving
them money in spite of their bad
behavior and they're buying drugs with
it they're buying alcohol with it
they're buying their I'm financing their
misbehavior and their inability to face
their things so his wife needs to get a
job the 18 year old needs to get a job
tomorrow and they need to be on a
written budget and be on a plan and
willing to show you all of that and by
the way if they do all that they won't
need you hmm
I won't need you they won't have they
won't need you financially and Tina's
got to get a community get a friend get
a pastor somebody to work through the
passing of her mom the slow pastor's
with a brother you start to feel crazy
when you're dealing crazy yeah if you
don't have somebody out there going
because we're sitting there saying your
assessment of the situation is accurate
and you need someone to tell you that
after you have sit-down with them
because you're gonna come way going oh
I'm just a mean person
mm-hmm you're just mean I had somebody
tell me that one time you're just mean
and I'm like no I'm not but it's hard
not to get in the car and think yeah did
I handle that right - um I mean no I'm
not me and you lately you set that on
the death of your mom that gets heavy
it gets heavy it really does